es un caso que podría desestabilizar sus
aspiraciones de reelección en 2024 el
segundo bloque de documentos
clasificados encontrados en su
residencia por su propio equipo de
abogados deja a Joe biden en el centro
de las miradas y será puesto bajo
investigación por decisión Del fiscal
general de Estados Unidos merry Garland
hoy estoy aquí para anunciar el
nombramiento de Robert Heart como
abogado especial en conformidad con las
normas del departamento de Justicia que
rigen estos asuntos de conformidad con
esas normas hoy he notificado a los
miembros designados de cada cámara del
Congreso de la cita
en una escueta comparecencia el
mandatario estadounidense afirmó que
cooperarán Y aunque no hay precisiones
sobre la cantidad de documentos dijo que
es pequeña
estamos cooperando total y completamente
con la revisión del departamento de
Justicia como parte de este proceso mis
abogados revisaron otros lugares donde
se almacenaron documentos de mi tiempo
como vicepresidente y terminaron la
revisión anoche descubrieron una pequeña
cantidad de documentos clasificados de
marcas y áreas de almacenamiento en
archivadores en mi casa y en mi
biblioteca personal
esto dio lugar a las críticas de los
republicanos quienes comparan la
situación de biden con la de Donald
Trump sin embargo hay profundas
diferencias entre un caso y el otro
al momento sólo son 10 los documentos
que estaban en posesión de biden
mientras que Trump albergó 325 en su
casa de Florida además el expresidente
se resistió entregarlos a la justicia
algo que no sucedió con el demócrata y
en el caso de biden los papeles hallados
no coinciden con su periodo como
presidente